un remaniement qui passe mal en tunisie
alors que le parlement a accordé sa
confiance au nouveau gouvernement le
président de la république tunisienne
kaïs sayyed a déjà émis de vives
critiques contre l'équipe choisie en
marge des tensions au sommet de l'état
des centaines de manifestants se sont
réunis ce mardi près du parlement
en cause la répression policière contre
le mouvement de contestation sociale qui
a commencé à la mi janvier
je suis ici pour réclamer des libertés
les droits et la justice
je suis venu aujourd'hui pour que tout
le monde soit ensemble
je suis venu ici aujourd'hui parce qu'en
tant que jeune cet état a dépensé pour
m'éduquer comme mes parents l'ont fait
pour que je puisse réclamer mes droits
la pandémie nous la combattons ensemble
mais pas au détriment d'autres problèmes
au lendemain du 10e anniversaire de la
révolution un mouvement de contestation
s'est propagée dans plusieurs villes du
pays
les tunisiens descendent dans les rues
depuis plus de dix jours pour protester
contre la crise économique sociale et
politique que traverse le pays
ces tensions se sont accentuées avec la
crise sanitaire aux politiciens je leur
dis une chose si vous avez quelque chose
à dire au peuple ne le dit pas avec les
forces de l'ordre ne le dit pas avec
l'aide du ministère de l'intérieur
sortait voir le peuple et fait lui face
en dix ans il n'y a aucune stratégie
perspectives pour l'avenir ni même
l'espoir que les choses changent
au contraire chaque année l'espoir
vimines est aujourd'hui en 2021
pratiquement tous les jeunes sont
désespérés tous les jeunes rêvent de
deux choses soit il émigrer
clandestinement
soit il s'immole des émeutes nocturnes
entre manifestants et forces de l'ordre
ont éclaté lors des premiers jours de
contestation face à la colère des jeunes
tunisiens
le premier ministre hichem mais chichi a
tenté de calmer les esprits ce mardi le
chef du gouvernement a assuré qu'il
serait à l'écouté des jeunes
protestataires